♪ ♪
>> Tucker: BIG NEWS THIS WEEK.
THE MIGRANT CARAVAN ACTUALLY
EXISTS.
IT'S RIGHT ACROSS THE U.S.
BORDER IN TIJUANA, MEXICO,
CAUSING HUGE PROBLEMS FOR THAT
CITY.
IT MAY BE A SURPRISE TO YOU
BECAUSE YOU HAVE BEEN HEARING
FOR WEEKS AND WEEKS THAT THEY
CARAVAN WASN'T REAL.
HE WOULD HAVE TO BE A RIGHT-WING
THEY GET TO THINK IT WAS.
THEN THEY TOLD YOU IT IS SO FAR
AWAY THAT IT'S IRRELEVANT.
WELL, THEN ON SUNDAY, THAT
IRRELEVANT IMAGINARY MIGRANT
CARAVAN ATTACKED AMERICAN BORDER
GUARDS.
THAT MAY SURPRISE YOU MORE STILL
BECAUSE YOU WERE TOLD THE
CARAVAN WAS ENTIRELY HARMLESS
AND AGAIN, IF YOU BELIEVE
OTHERWISE, YOU'RE A BAD PERSON.
SOON, A NEW STORY -- WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT IS BUT WE CAN BE
SURE THERE IS ONE -- WILL COME
TO DOMINATE THE HEADLINES.
THE MIGRANT CARAVAN WILL BE
MOSTLY FORGOTTEN.
EVEN IF THE BORDER CRISIS
REMAINS
UNRESOLVED.
THE PUBLIC, THE PRESS, THE
PRESIDENT LIKELY COME TOO, WILL
HAVE MOVED ON.
WE WANT TO PAUSE FOR A MOMENT AS
BEFORE THAT HAPPENS, AND IT WILL
INEVITABLY HAPPEN, AND LOOK BACK
AND CONSIDER HOW THIS STORY WAS
HANDLED BY THE PRESS.
BECAUSE WE THINK IT MATTERS.
THE STORY EVOLVED RAPIDLY AND
THE MEDIA'S OFFICIAL STORY
EVOLVED JUST AS RAPIDLY.
BUT WHERE THEIR DESCRIPTIONS
ABOUT WHAT WAS HAPPENING
FACTUALLY ON THE GROUND TRUE?
TONIGHT WE WANT TO INVESTIGATE
THAT.
THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN QUESTION,
BY THE WAY.
IT IS ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THE
COUNTRY.
FOR A FREE SOCIETY TO FUNCTION,
THE PRESS DOES NOT HAVE TO BE
PERFECT, BUT IT DOES HAVE TO BE
BETTER THAN EIGHT PROPAGANDA
OUTLET.
ARE THEY?
LET'S BREAK IT DOWN WITH BUCK
SEXTON, A FORMER CIA ANALYST AND
HOST OF "THE BUCK SEXTON SHOW"
AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
BUCK, THANKS A LOT FOR COMING
ON.
YOU'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THIS
REALLY CLOSELY, YOU HAD AN
INCISIVE BREAKDOWN OF THE
COVERAGE AND SO I WANT TO PUT
THESE QUESTIONS TO YOU.
AS A CLAIM NUMBER ONE.
THE MIGRANT CARAVAN WE WERE TOLD
IS MOSTLY WOMEN AND CHILDREN WHO
POSE NO THREAT TO ANYBODY.
HERE'S ONE EXAMPLE.
WOW OF THAT CLAIM.
>> ALL OF THIS WERE A GROUP OF
PEOPLE, A LOT OF WHOM WHO ARE
MOTHERS AND CHILDREN WHO POSE NO
IMMINENT THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES.
>> MANY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
>> Tucker: OH, THE TALKING
POINT.
REMEMBER IT.
WAS A TRUE?
>> NO, IN FACT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THAT MARK WHAT WE WOULD CALL
MILITARY AGE MALES.
THESE ARE GUYS MOSTLY IN THEIR
GUIDES ON MY 20s AND 30s.
THAT WAS APPARENT, TUCKER.
THERE'S NAME IS REPORTING THAT
YOU WOULD EXPECT THE PEOPLE
MAKING AN HONEST MISTAKE AND
THEN THERE'S A LOT OF
JOURNALISTS GATHER TOGETHER
BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN TALKING TO
JOURNALISTS ALL THROUGHOUT THIS
CARAVAN'S PROGRESSION, AND THERE
HAS BEEN THIS MARCH APPLIES.
THERE'VE BEEN SOME PEOPLE
TELLING THE TRUTH BUT ONLY --
YOU GO DOWN THERE, AND ITS GUYS,
MOSTLY GUYS.
THERE ARE SOME WOMEN AND
CHILDREN THERE BUT THE FOCUS IS
CLEARLY DISHONEST PARADES WE
WOULD OF COURSE.
CLAIM NUMBER TWO, THE CARAVAN,
WE WERE TOLD, AGAIN, AGAIN, IS M
WE WERE TOLD, AGAIN, AGAIN, IS S
WE WERE TOLD, AGAIN, AGAIN, IS L
WE WERE TOLD, AGAIN, AGAIN, IS Y
WE WERE TOLD, AGAIN, AGAIN, IS C
WE WERE TOLD, AGAIN, AGAIN, IS M
WE WERE TOLD, AGAIN, AGAIN, IS R
WE WERE TOLD, AGAIN, AGAIN, IS S
WE WERE TOLD, AGAIN, AGAIN, IS D
WE WERE TOLD, AGAIN, AGAIN, IS O
WE WERE TOLD, AGAIN, AGAIN, IS F
WE WERE TOLD, AGAIN, AGAIN, IS G
WE WERE TOLD, AGAIN, AGAIN, IS N
WE WERE TOLD, AGAIN, AGAIN, IS I
WE WERE TOLD, AGAIN, AGAIN, IS E
ASYLUM SEEKERS SEEKING.
>> THESE PEOPLE ARE COMING AND
ASKING FOR ASYLUM.
GUESS WHAT?
IT'S IN OUR LAWS THAT PEOPLE ARE
ALLOWED TO COME TO OUR BORDERS
AND ASK FOR ASYLUM.
>> Tucker: YEAH, IT IS OUR
FAULT FOR NOT WELCOMING THEM
BECAUSE THEY ARE SINCERE
ASYLUM-SEEKERS.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> NO, IT'S A SCAM.
THEY KNOW IT'S A SCAM BASED ON
THE PERCENTAGE OF PERCENTAGE
INDIVIDUALS AND THE PASTOR OF,
TRIED TO CLAIM ASYLUM IN THIS
WAY AND THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
BEING COACHED TO LIVE.
THIS IS ACTUALLY A FORM OF
FRAUD.
WHEN YOU SAY THAT I AM AN M&A
PAIR OF MY LIFE BECAUSE PEOPLE
ALONG THE WAY HAVE SAID,
THIS IS WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY TO
GET INTO THE ASYLUM PROCESS, YOU
CAN LATER BE ADJUDICATED, YOU
ARE LYING TO PEOPLE IN A VAST
MAJORITY OF THESE CASES.
BY THE WAY, IF JUST BEING FROM
HONDURAS, FOR EXAMPLE, MEANS YOU
ARE AT THE JAKARTA VIOLENCE YOU
COULD GET ASYLUM, THEN THE WHOLE
COUNTRY COULD QUALIFY FOR
ASYLUM.
THIS IS A SCAM AND PEOPLE
REALIZE THAT NOW BUT THEN THE
MEDIA WAS PRETENDING IT DOESN'T.
>> Tucker: WHY DOESN'T THE
COUNTRY QUALIFY FOR ASYLUM?
I'M SURE WE WILL HEAR THAT IT
DOES.
CLAIM NUMBER THREE, THERE ARE NO
CRIMINALS AND THE CARAVAN.
>> I SPENT TWO DAYS WITH THE
CARAVAN AND I DID NOT SEE
CRIMINALS OR RAPISTS OR TERRACE.
>> STOP SAYING THEY ARE
MONSTERS.
THEY ARE MORE MOTHERS THAN
>> Tucker: HOW DO THE DUMB
PEOPLE GET ON TV?
THERE ARE MORE MOTHERS THAN
MONSTERS.
>> AN OFFICIAL STATEMENT FROM
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT HAS ABOUT 600 KNOWN
CRIMINALS, BY THE WAY, PEOPLE
THAT WE ARE SURE HAVE A CRIMINAL
RECORD APART FROM TRYING TO
CROSS THE BORDER AND PERHAPS
THROW SOME ROCKS AT SOME FEDERAL
AGENTS, AND OH, BY THE WAY,
SPEAKING WITH JOURNALISTS EARLY
ON IN THIS, TUCKER, SAID THEY
ARE PRETTY SURE THERE ARE
CRIMINALS BECAUSE THEIR WHOLE
BUNCH OF GUYS COVERED IN MS-13
TATTOOS, WHICH ARE VERY
PROMINENT, WHO ARE MARCHING
ALONG WITH THE CARAVAN, TOO.
THIS WAS NOT FROM THE BEGINNING
THE PEOPLE CHOSE TO FOCUS ON
OTHER THINGS.
>> Tucker: WHERE THEY MS-13
MOTHERS NOT MONSTERS, OR WERE
THEY MEN?
>> I SUPPOSE THAT IS POSSIBLE
BUT THE MEDIA WAS TRYING TO FIND
A WAY TO AVOID THE FACT THAT
THERE WERE BAD FOLKS AND HIS
GROUP RATES.
WHEN THEY WERE LYING.
CLAIM NUMBER VOCAL, THIS COMES
FROM A FORMER COMMANDER IN
CHIEF.
THE CARAVAN DOES NOT MATTER.
YOU ARE A BAD PERSON FOR
WORRYING ABOUT IT BECAUSE THE
VERY FAR AWAY.
>> THEY ARE TELLING YOU THAT
THEY ARE AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT
TO AMERICA IS A BUNCH OF
POOR REFUGEES A THOUSAND MILES
AWAY.
THIS GROUP OF FOLKS, WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHERE THEY ARE, THEY
ARE WAY DOWN THERE.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE WAY DOWN
THERE.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE THEY
ARE, BUCK.
>> BUSES AND TRAINS EXIST IN
MEXICO, WHICH I THINK
JOURNALISTS KNOW, ESPECIALLY
JOURNALISTS IN MEXICO REPORTING
ON THIS BUT THERE WAS ALWAYS
THIS, WELL, IT'S GOING TO TAKE
THEM FOREVER TO MARGE.
NOW, BY THE WAY, WITH SOME HELP,
THEY GOT ON BUSES, TRAINS, OTHER
MODES OF TRANSPORTATION, GOT TO
THE BORDER.
IF THEY WERE ACTUALLY REFUGEES
AS OBAMA SAID, THEY SHOULD CLAIM
REFUGEE STATUS IN THE FIRST
COUNTRY THEY ARRIVE IN, WHERE
THEY ARE NO LONGER UNDER MORTAL
THREAT.
MEXICO HAS OFFER THEM ASYLUM,
THEY SAID NO BECAUSE THEY ARE
NOT REFUGEES, THEY ARE JUST
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO GET TO THE
FRONT OF THE LINE FOR
IMMIGRATION.
>> Tucker: SUCH A GREAT POINT.
JORGE RAMOS OF UNIVISION CAME ON
THIS PROGRAM TO PRESENT A CLAIM
NUMBER FIVE THAT THE CARAVAN
RECEIVED NO EXTERNAL SUPPORT.
>> I KNOW THAT THERE ARE FAKE
STORIES IN UNITED STATES SAYING
THAT THESE PEOPLE WERE FUNDED BY
GEORGE SOROS AND BY DEMOCRATS
AND NICOLAS MADURO FROM
VENEZUELA.
IF THEY REALLY FIND OUT THESE
PEOPLE, IT WAS A SCAM.
I HAVE BEEN TALKING TO PEOPLE
HERE WHO DON'T HAVE A SINGLE
DOLLAR, TUCKER, TO BUY A BOTTLE
OF WATER.
SO THERE IS NO FINANCING HERE.
>> Tucker: NO FINANCING AT
ALL.
BY THE WAY, YOU ARE A MORAL WHO
CLAIM OTHERWISE.
>> IT'S A LIE.
I TALK TO JOURNALISTS WHO ARE
SEEING PEOPLE WHO ARE HANDING
OUT FOOD, GATHERING DONATIONS
TOGETHER SO THEY CAN BUY FOOD
AND EQUIPMENT.
WHEN YOU GOT SIX, 7,000 PEOPLE
TOGETHER, THAT IS GOING TO BE A
DIFFICULT LOGISTICAL CHALLENGE.
UNLESS THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
THERE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT AND
THERE CLEARLY ARE PEOPLE
PROVIDING SUPPORT.
SO AGAIN, JOURNALISTS WANTED TO
KNOW THE STUFF, SOME OF THEM DO
BUT THEY JUST DON'T GET AS MUCH
AIR TIME ON PLACES LIKE CNN
AND MSNBC, THEY COULD WIND UP OR
THEY DON'T WANT TO KNOW, THEY
JUST WANT TO REPRESENT PEOPLE
GETTING TEARGAS, MOTHERS AND
CHILDREN, IF YOU DON'T LIKE
THIS, YOU ARE A MONSTER, THE
REALITY IS IS IS A MASSIVE SCAM,
THERE'S A LOT OF OUTSIDE HELP,
AND THERE ARE LAWS THAT ARE
BEING BROKEN.
>> Tucker: FINALLY, WE HAVE A
SIXTH CLAIM, THAT DEPLOYING
TROOPS TO THE BORDER WAS
WRONG, BUT IT WAS ALSO
COMPLETELY UNNECESSARY.
A "NEW YORK TIMES" CARTOONIST
PUT IT, "TROOPS SIGN UP TO FIGHT
IN AN OBSCURE COUNTRY IN THE
MIDDLE EAST, NOT TO GUARD THEIR
OWN COUNTRIES BORDER."
KAMALA HARRIS AGREED WITH THAT.
>> IT IS INAPPROPRIATE TO
REQUIRE THE LIMITED RESOURCES OF
UNITED STATES MILITARY TO BE
USED IN SUCH A WAY, ALL BECAUSE
THERE NEEDED TO BE SOME
DEMONSTRATION FOR THE TV CAMERAS
BASED ON THE POLITICAL AGENDA
INSTEAD OF WHAT IS THE NATIONAL
SECURITY THREAT.
>> Tucker: SO WHY ARE THEY IN
SYRIA WHERE THEY BELONG?
>> ALSO, WHY CAN'T A
SENATOR HARRIS CALL DOWN TO
BORDER PATROL AND SAY, OR
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT FOR THAT MATTER, DO
YOU THINK IT'S HELPFUL?
THE ANSWER IS YES.
I'VE SPOKEN TO BORDER PATROL AND
THEY SAY THAT A LOGISTICAL
SUPPORT THAT THE MILITARY WAS
GIVEN THEM WAS IN FACT VERY
MUCH-NEEDED BECAUSE THE CARAVAN
WAS ARRIVING AND THERE WERE
REAL CONCERNS THAT THEY WOULD
TRY TO OVERRUN THE BORDER,
WHICH, TUCKER, IS EXACTLY WHAT
THEY DID DO.
SO WE JUST HAD THIS PROGRESSION
OF LIES ALONG THE WAY.
IN EVERY STAGE, IT SEEMS THE
MEDIA ALWAYS GETS IT WRONG ON
ONE DIRECTION AND THAT IS
SOMEHOW, WE ARE EXAGGERATING
THIS RIGHT WHEN IN FACT WE ARE
UNDERESTIMATING THE REALITY OF
HOW BIGGEST PROBLEM IS GOING TO